[Music]
hello welcome to dear Hank and John
Norris I refer to think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where
being my brother John answer your
questions give you dubious advice to
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon John tell me
about how you're doing I'm doing
wonderfully Hank because at the AFC
Wimbledon news there's good there's good
and there's bad in the world right now
Hank as is usually the case but right
now for me the good is outweighing the
bad the bad being I'm in a lot of dental
pain also the Sun has not shown here in
Indianapolis for like 73 consecutive
days it's been too long since Taylor
Swift played a concert here obviously
but on the upside Hank AFC Wimbledon I'm
not even gonna wait till the end of the
podcast AFC Wimbledon wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait there so that's
the whole reason for the end of the
podcast you gotta make them wait are you
kidding I have tons of news from AFC
Wimbledon for the end of the podcast but
Hank just to establish this at the
outset AFC Wimbledon are in the playoffs
they are in the league to playoffs and
in fact they have a 25% chance of having
a 100% chance of playing next year in
the third tier of English football
that's very weird and exciting I believe
that hope is the thing with feathers and
I actually have been following AFC
Wimbledon a surprising amount since we
have not recorded the podcast in a
couple of weeks I felt like I wasn't
getting enough AFC Wimbledon news and
I'm sure you did the same with the Mars
news that you've been there on Google
News search and Mars seeing what's up
and and you know you're probably up to
date as well well I mean the nice thing
about Mars news is that it's sort of
year-round AFC Wimbledon news really
reaches this like peak intensity once a
year but I have been following the news
from Mars actually I in fact I have a
guess what I think your news from Mars
is gonna be this week but anyway how are
you you're about to go on tour for to
support I was gonna say your new album
but in fact you don't have a new well
now I don't though this week I will be
releasing a new song but no new no new
album too many things going on I have
enough new material for a new album but
we just haven't had the time to record
it the yeah so we're just we're bad I'm
excited about whenever whenever you're
ready for a new album I'm very excited
okay well we are going on tour in Texas
a little bit of Arizona and California
and also Lawrence Kansas which
remarkably is one of our best-selling
stops you wouldn't think Lawrence Kansas
among stops like Austin in Los Angeles
and Dallas and Houston and and San
Francisco would be one of our best
sellers but there it is John you never
know where nerdfighteria is it always
surprises you
can I read you a poem oh yes of course
Hank it will surprise and delight you to
learn that today's poem comes from Emily
Dickinson oh there is no frigate like a
book to take us lands away nor any
coursers like a page of prancing poetry
this traverse may the poorest take
without oppressive toll how frugal is
the chariot that bears the human soul
Emily Dickinson with a little love song
two books Hank it was a little a little
love song that was it that was a short
short poem John now I like I'm short
that's I apologize for not having
anything more intelligent than that to
say but but it's fine let's get to the
questions from our lips I want to I want
to switch up the format a little bit and
do first a little bit of feedback from a
listener this is from Tom who says that
last episode or in a previous episode
yuba moaned
that there was no band called toxic
megacolon but in fact there is one there
is a band
it appears be a university band on
Columbia Medical University and they
have a few YouTube videos so toxic mega
toxic megacolon it's a band of med
students yeah you should search for it
on youtube but when you search for toxic
megacolon on youtube you must do so very
cautiously agreed a creep another bit of
feedback Hank our favorite podcast my
brother my brother and me mentioned us
in fact called us geniuses so thanks my
brother my brother and me all those
McElroy brothers they're geniuses -
they're the geniuses and our
a bit of feedback before we get to
questions from our listeners comes from
Sarah who writes dear John and Hank I'd
like to present a counter-argument to
John's frequent point that all of us and
everything are destined for oblivion
according to physics matter cannot be
created or destroyed merely changed that
even includes the brain cells that
formed this thought and when we die the
matter that makes us will be recycled
back into the universe for as long as it
exists and perhaps will be part of
whatever follows it that's not good news
to me Sarah no because what you're
basically telling me is that like later
like my thoughts will be turned into
like poop and dirt and I don't find that
to be at all comforting but good try it
really all comes down to what identity
is and if you want to talk more about
that go over to check out crash course
where I'm currently teaching philosophy
at youtube.com slash crash course and
that was a I have to say Hank that was a
hard one plug well we just talked about
that we just talked about the ship of
theseus and how all of our body gets
replaced and yet we still exist and what
is what is us anyway and I can I can
tell you that us is not the atoms that
make us off well Hank I will tell you
that the ship of theseus is not not in
my new book all right what you want to
do some questions job yes let's answer
some questions from our beloved
listeners this question is from zoe who
asks dear Hank and John I recently sent
John a lot of snapchats but he hasn't
answered any of them that yet I wanted
to know whether you answer your snaps
yourself or have some kind of snapchat
manager or if you answer them at all I
do not have a snapchat manager although
I find that idea hilarious I mean the
great thing about snapchat is that you
sort of can't fake it you know you can't
schedule snapchats at least as far as I
know and you can't have like your you
know your assistant snapchat for you
because they can tell if it's your face
or not right I mean you could you could
give the phone to someone and have them
like go out and pointed it things and
then write John Green II kind of quotes
on the bottom of them but but no do you
do you even know that you can get snaps
from other people I know that I can get
snaps from other people because I
Sara and I since nap chats of the kids
back and forth to each other quite a bit
using the hilarious filters but I don't
know much about snap chatting with
strangers that seems like a risky
business and one that I would do well to
avoid so it's it's truly nothing
personal yeah I just I don't really know
how to do that and I don't think it's
something that I want to learn how to do
I think that there's I think that I
think that you can actually I have it
turned off I cannot get snaps from
strangers but I don't know that
strangers can't send them to me I just
know that I can't see them so it's
possible that you're sending snapchats
into a kind of void I definitely cannot
see a snapchat if you send it to me yeah
so we're sorry that our snapchats have
to be a one-way street but we just feel
like that is the right that's a way yeah
it's definitely the right way I think we
have another question this one comes
from Rachel who asks Dear John and Hank
when I was a kid my mom told me not to
look at the microwave while it was
running because it was bad for my eyes
is that true no no it isn't true but I
have to say I say that to my kids even
though I know it's not true and I also
tell my kids that they can't stand too
close to the television because it will
be bad for their eyes even though I also
know that's not true and there are times
in fact when I say Henry you're standing
too close to the TV and he just turns
around and says why why is this too
close to the TV why is there like a
preset distance between the TV and me
that is acceptable according to my
father and I don't really know the
answer to that question but I know that
I'm right yeah I mean I remember when I
was a kid I would want to sit as close
to the TV as possible which is very
strange to me now yeah because I
experienced pain when I get too close to
the television but I guess that pain is
a kind of joy when you're a child it's
just like oh the stimulus
I am so stimulated I could all of the
photons hmm but ya know microwaves are
pretty safe and the the waves that that
might be destructive you would feel them
as heat because that's how they would
that's that that's what they do they
interact with water and if they were
reaching you you would you would think
ah I feel warm if you ever feel
like you've turned your microwave on and
and you're feeling warmth coming out of
it like it's like radiating out of that
that's because there's something very
wrong and the screen has been removed
the metal screen that protects you from
the microwaves my grandfather actually
once told me a story about how he would
stand in Korea in the Korean War would
stand in front of the microwave antennas
to warm up which is not a good idea
which grandfather mom stat really yeah
now I don't want to question your memory
but I'm reasonably sure that our
maternal grandfather did not serve in
the armed forces during the Korean
conflict this is a manufactured memory
but I think but I do want a text mom and
ask her but he did serving in World War
two I don't believe he served in Korea
but what do I know I'm just his grandson
you you know him better knew him better
than I did
so I mean only barely just because he
once gave me an extremely intense
lecture when I was a junior in high
school as the main way in which I was
closer to our grandfather than you were
because I went to boarding school and he
pulled me out one day in the middle of
school and told me that I was not taking
my opportunities seriously and that I
was a disgrace Wow which actually turned
out to be really helpful I yeah I it is
it is often that we manufacture our
memories but but I know that that is
that that that is the thing that could
work and I can't imagine that whether or
not our grandfather actually warmed up
near microwave radio towers he could
have he could have absolutely good have
we'll get another question from Anna
Katharine who asks dear Hank and John I
dislike showers showers are bothersome
they take up time that I could be using
to read or watch a TV show or doing my
college work practicing an instrument or
listening to your podcast they just seem
like a waste of time do you have any
tips for how to enjoy a shower you may
well share yes oh
man yes I do I do I do not know how to
not enjoy a show I completely agree with
anna catherine showers are intensely
unenjoyable because you are alone with
your own thoughts you are aware that
yourself is a prison from which you can
never escape it is an awful awful thing
and you're being pelted by water you're
essentially being like attacked by very
low level the watery gunfire I should
have I should have not even asked a
question because I should have known
that it would have been immediately been
a you are uncomfortable with your own
thoughts job I don't know that I don't
know that this is as common as you seem
to think it is maybe it is yeah I I do
sometimes lament activities that should
be enjoyable because I need to get other
stuff done but I I maybe maybe sing yeah
and be sing some songs in there maybe
maybe maybe have an agenda before you go
in and say I'm gonna think about these
three things yeah I'm gonna deal with
some issues but more than anything what
helps me really enjoy a shower is being
cold beforehand because there's nothing
I like more than warming up and I I am
often cold because I live in Montana
so here's my answer Anna Katherine stop
taking showers do what your ancestors
did and bathe in still water then you
can listen to a podcast if you're
willing to to risk it holding holding
your phone over the bath water you can
even watch a show while you're taking a
bath all the things that you don't like
about showering you you can fix by
bathing I I don't really understand
baths but but is it just the process of
laying there that gets you clean you
must actually have to scrub it and stuff
what's that delaying their portion isn't
oh sure at some point you have to soap
up but you're listening to a podcast
it's right okay so yeah but you can't
have like your hands holding a phone no
I like to read for the first what I
usually do is I usually read a book
for the first 20 minutes of my bath 20
minutes yeah
this is not helping Ana Catherine save
time well I mean she's trying to save
time so that she can do the things she
enjoys doing like reading watching TV
shows and listening to our podcast all
of which you can do in the bath yeah I
okay but I don't think that you're
actually getting clean during that time
you're just laying in your own film at
that that part you're just soaking
you're just letting the day's stresses
just leave your body I recommend a nice
bath ball from lush I do I do it not to
advertise but and and just just let all
of the stresses of the day leave your
body as you read your book and listen to
your podcast or watch your TV show and
then once you're in this sort of like
beatific state that accompanies a good
perfectly temperature fall bath bomb
kind of bath then then you start the
scrubbing and the shampooing and
everything and it's it's almost by then
you're so relaxed you don't mind okay I
don't understand baths that I'm never
going to we got out of the question
it's from Naomi who asks dear Hank and
John I'm going to college next year and
I found my roommate through Facebook
we've only met briefly one time in
person and I'm nervous about becoming
friends since we're both introverts how
do I become friends with my new roommate
and how were your college roommates well
I think Hank have you ever seen the
movie speed of the one with Keanu Reeves
and and and Sandra Bullock yeah
Keanu Reeves and Sandra Bullock share a
very intense experience and they don't
have a lot in common but because they've
shared this really intense experience of
being on a bus that if it went below 50
miles an hour was going to explode at
the end of the movie they end up dating
and they are dating because they
actually liked each other or anything
like that they're just dating because
they they did this amazing weird thing
together and I think that's kind of what
having your college roommate is like you
become friends just because you're doing
this weird intense thing together now
hopefully you also turn out to be like
well matched and have a good long-term
friendship but the the initial
connection is just like can you believe
that we're doing
right yeah no I think that's right
that's a really good point
I think that there are ways to foster it
and to end to open and opening yourself
up can be very hard but but I I
generally think that people respond to
to people letting people respond to
trust with trust they respond to being
trusted by being trustworthy and I think
that like opening up and saying like I'm
going to I'm going to trust you with
some bits of me that will cause them to
open up and then it is that then like
friendship is sort of a foregone
conclusion at that point yeah you know I
actually remembered the very first
conversation I had with my college
roommate meet you we're not in great
touch now but we were we were very close
friends for a long time I said I believe
this is the one of the first things ever
said to him I said there's something
that you should know I smoked cigarettes
I won't do it in the room or anything
and then he said well there's something
that you should know I know the middle
names of all of the US presidents and I
was like I think we'll get along fine i
I just remember it being very like I
don't remember that the content of the
conversation but I remember where we
were sitting and how we were sitting and
and like it was it was weird because we
were in the wrong room they our room
wasn't ready so we were like basically
in a hotel room and and we just yeah we
just chilled and like we're very open
and it was like it was sort of like the
most open we were in our whole
relationship was that first conversation
and and you know he turned out to you
know have very different interests than
me and and so that first college
roommate we didn't become great friends
but but I felt a little bit like even
though he had these really good friends
that were like you know in his like sort
of interest areas that when there was
like bigger stuff he would come to me
with that stuff almost just because I
was there and also not involved in all
of that right that's a good point
you're gonna be okay is the long and
short of it I think I think most of our
advice boils down to you're going to
you okay yeah no I definitely think you
got and then there's that little there's
that little like ten percent of the
advice that's like you're gonna be okay
but we're all gonna die it's always good
to throw that in so you're also kind of
not not gonna be okay you know like if
you're gonna be okay in the short run
but in the long run I am concerned ank
we have another question this one comes
from Erica who writes Dear John and Hank
just recently half an hour ago I broke
my favorite mug it was yellow and had a
cute little handle it has no sentimental
value but it was undoubtedly the best
mug in my apartment and I used it
practically every day no other mug has
ever measured up and it feels so odd
using the past tense here because I
can't believe it is gone my question is
how long is the appropriate mourning
period for a broken mug I feel like I
lost a friend or something I cried a lot
when it first broke and I tear up every
time I think about it bear in mind every
time I think about it been 30 minutes
I wish I didn't cry so easily but I
think that might be a separate issue
yeah I'm glad that you didn't write in
about I have no advice on crying too
much except that I also do it any advice
on how to get over the loss of a truly
unique and excellent mug well Erica I
suspect that you are over it that it
that in the time that it took you took
us to answer your question you move
through all five of the stages of grief
I know what it's like though to lose
something that that you really like and
it's a stupid little thing but you still
you still miss it it made your life
better in a little way in fact I still
remember Hank you probably don't
remember this at all but one time mom
had this cookie jar that she really
loved how it was dad's cookie jar Tuggle
no I remember Tuggle dad's cookies well
okay you tell the story because
apparently I don't remember any of it
well I will just say that mom just
texted me back and indeed papa served in
in World War two so I you were right
about that but I was right about this
cookie jar and yah I'm gonna text mom
about the cookie jar while you well you
tell the story so yeah
it was I mean you have children and you
have ceramic things you must know that
there is a there is a high chance that
that ceramic thing is going to stop
existing at some point and indeed Tuggle
the cookie jar it was a cookie jar in
the shape of a tugboat did did not
survive our childhood and I couldn't
even tell you that was a bad day though
I remember it was a very bad day was it
me I think it was kind of us I think it
was one of those real shared blame
moments well yeah it was and indeed you
I would not have thought that they would
have been so distraught or that dad
would have been so distraught about the
destruction of of this that's tugboat
cookie jar but you never know you never
know what the thing is that you feel
this deep connection to and maybe
contains some memories although Erica
goes to lengths to point out that the
mug had no sentimental value at all my
you know my main advice Erica would be
to go to dftba.com and get yourself a
couple of brand new mugs because they're
affordable they're excellent quality and
you'll find that they serve in almost
exactly the same fashion as your yellow
mug with the cute little handle you
answered this question purely so you
could plug mugs on dftba.com didn't you
John just be honest and say I answered
the question purely so that I could
remind people they can get excellent
coffee mugs and t-shirts and other
things at dftba.com right now but I do
think that it's an important part of the
question just to remind people that
dftba.com is your home for excellent
mugs t-shirts posters and it's etc what
was that URL again John I think I may
have forgotten it oh it's easy to
remember Hank it's don't forget to be
awesome but just you just shortened it
into an initialism so that it's
dftba.com and once you go there you'll
just be overwhelmed by the consumer
products that are available to you all
as such astonishingly high quality and
yet at the same time surprisingly
affordable I think John it may be
possible that today's broadcast is
brought to you by dftba.com dftba.com
where you can get all of the things that
you might want that should be our real
tagline and today's podcast is also
brought to you by toxic megacolon
SiC megacolon not just a terrible
disease also a band in New York City
this podcast is additionally brought to
you by stewing in your own filth for 20
minutes while reading a book cause
that's supposed to get you clean
oh man I do not apologize and of course
the day's podcasts and to not I do not
and of course today's podcast is also
brought to you by snapchat snapchat Hank
is it Hank GRE and it really makes him
happy when you follow him on snapchat oh
man I I have so many thoughts on
snapchat that I'm going to move right on
and not talk about any of them lest we
talk about snapchat for the entire
podcast this question is from Piper it's
very important John yeah Piper asks dear
Hank and John why is it that soft chunky
chips chips as in french fries taste so
much worse than thin crispy chips it
can't simply be because they're bigger
because I could put three small chips
together and it would taste better than
the mushy big chips is there some sort
of scientific answer here it can't
possibly be personal preference because
everyone knows that small crispy chips
are better well I mean part of it is
personal preference right because some
people like so-called steak fries or
right yeah steak fries that's what they
call them anymore the large crispy chips
I personally enjoy what are usually
known as shoestring fries yeah for
instance you get at at Steak and Shake I
like those this the shoestring er the
better and I think it boils down to the
same thing a few weeks ago we talked
about why regular M&Ms are in our
opinion so much better than many M&Ms
but many people like mini M&Ms better it
all boils down to either candy -
chocolate ratio or in this case I think
Frei - potato ratio right yeah yeah
because there's that that crispy like
like just eating a cooked like a baked
potato it's got it it's got its perks
but you're gonna put a bunch of butter
and sour cream on there or chili or
something
cheese because it's like just a potato
while you know containing lots of
nutrition does not have a great flavor
it's pretty bland but if you fry it you
get a little bit of that some kind of
chemical reaction going on where you get
the crispness and there's also some
added flavor and also that added oil
which is basically your butter
substitute and oils good so you get that
mix of both the starch and the fat and
and I feel like there's got there's like
an optimal ratio there and you want in
general more fat to starch because we're
humans and in that that's all good
that's all good stuff for our for our
energy needs well that's very
interesting hey I'm gonna move on to a
serious question now if we can this
questions from Guillaume GM i don't know
i'm not i'm really bad at pronouncing
French names Dear John and Hank I only
had 3 years of high school French I'm a
34 year old guy with two kids 6 and 3
I've been with my wife for 14 years and
today she announced she doesn't love me
anymore and wants to leave I'm a bit of
a loner and she's been almost my only
friend in those years she's more
outgoing and has always wanted to do
more things with her friends while I've
pulled back even more with the kids and
all the things that we had to do and all
the bad nights that's what drove her
away I wasn't doing enough she lost some
friends and now she realized were too
different she feels like she's going to
be more happy without me with someone
else I obviously don't want her to leave
but it looks like it's going to happen
winning her back seems hard but letting
her go seems harder I'm a very rational
guy and I understand that I might find
happiness in the future but I see the
road ahead and I'm not sure I want to
face it any dubious advice that's a very
serious question John you you picked out
I think maybe the most serious question
we got this month I actually we got so
many questions about divorce in the last
two weeks Hank that I felt like we
should answer one of them because I I
mean the short answer for me is that
you're right that the short term road
ahead is going to be very difficult no
matter what you know and I I don't know
the particulars of your situation I
don't know if it makes sense to go to
couples counseling I don't know you know
what makes sense for your family you
guys are gonna have to figure that
but it will be hard and sometimes
there's something really overwhelming
about knowing that you're facing a hard
you know year or two years or who knows
how long but at the same time I think
you're also right that you can find
happiness in the future and that it this
time won't be merely hard it will also
be many other things and that's the best
kind of hope that I can offer I think it
isn't going to be easy divorce isn't
easy it's extremely extremely difficult
but it's also it's not the end of your
life it's not the end of end of your
world yeah I mean I I if I was in that
situation more than anything I you know
there there are a lot of things to mourn
there I think that it's a it's kind of a
grieving process and has to be
considered to be you know like
understand that this is going to be
tough for a lot of different reasons and
that that's normal and natural and and
like losing the stability that your life
had and you know and having to go into
this no new unknown future is no fun but
yeah there's a lot of grief there for
knowing that and I think in some ways
probably yeah treating it as grief is
probably useful you know to understand
that you don't like when you're in a
grieving process you don't wake up one
day better you know it's just this it's
a slow transformation and understanding
that yeah I think not denying that is
really important but there's no at least
that I've that I've seen from from my
friends who've been through divorce
there's no easy way to go through it but
but there is another side you know like
there is you life does go on and life
can be very fulfilling and good again I
have another question John this one's
from Robin who asks dear Hank and John
one of my favorite things to do every
day is to listen to podcasts while I
walk my dog Murray when Murray and I are
out
we are controlled walking not smelling
flowers and definitely not chit-chatting
with neighbors but the weather is
getting nicer and more people are
outside and so
many old people are out trying to find
people to talk to I don't like feeling
obligated to smile and wave at these
strangers I just want to listen to my
pod but I can't help feeling guilty or
worse mad at them for making me feel
guilty
am I being rude am I the problem what's
the best way to walk past my neighbors
this feels more like a John question
because I'm totally the annoying talky
person and I feel bad maybe for it now
for being the annoying talky person who
is like take your headphones out let's
make a connection we're all experiencing
this beautiful life together we might as
well talk about it can I pet your dog I
feel like you might be less of that kind
of person well I don't totally disagree
with you Hank because I do think that
like you know life is life is social and
when you're in social spaces it's good
to smile and and wave even if it feels
like an obligation like making those
tiny social connections as a huge part
of what a lot of people find fulfilling
about being on earth and I think it's
very difficult to have a life that's
completely separated from all other
people like humans aren't aren't really
designed to be Islands although
obviously you know lots of people have
different ways of connecting to others
etc but I will say that one time I was
on an airplane and the woman sitting
next to me was very anxious and I am
also very anxious Hank and I don't know
if you know this but when you pluck a
perfectly tuned g-string a g-string on
an instrument far away from that
instrument but not too far will also
begin to vibrate did you know that yes I
did that I did know that
yeah so sometimes when I went when
somebody who is a very anxious person
when their string is vibrating I feel
that vibration very intensely because I
am also a very anxious person and so
this this person was very very anxious
about flying and I'm sympathetic to the
problem because I I am also a bit of an
anxious flier but I was just trying to
survive my flight so I put headphones in
as a way of saying as politely as I
could
I need this conversation to be over and
woman reached over and she touched my
ear who's a stranger we were not
acquainted touched my ear and she
removed the earbud from my ear and I
have never in my life come closer to
just disappearing
I barely near just ceased to be I I
thought you were gonna say I very nearly
like literally physically attacked a
person because that is no no no I didn't
have any desire to hurt this person I
just had an intense desire not to be
where I was I mean yes and I wanted it
so badly that it almost happened I
almost wasn't where I was anyway long
all of which is just to say that I'm
sympathetic to Robyn's position about
you know what wanting to be left alone
but at the same time like when you go
out into a social space like you have to
understand that part of that is waving
at strangers I think it's fine to have
headphones in and then you can just sort
of wave and smile rather than having a
whole conversation because if someone
starts to speak to you you can just
point at the ears and hopefully they
won't reach over touch your ears and
remove the earbud from your ears and
presumably if that does happen Marie
will be there to support you and I have
to say that there is a adorable picture
of Marie hiding in a bathtub which we
will attempt to put on the patreon for
everyone to see
I have I think one last question before
we get to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John okay it's from px who
asks dear Hank and John thank you for
the podcast it's one of the highlights
of my week Thank You px the question is
in what ways do you think your
experiences of the last nine years would
have been different or similar if
instead of being the vlogbrothers you
were the vlog sisters huh that's a
really interesting question
I think the first I don't think we would
have done it IIIi certainly don't think
that we would have been able to build an
audience and in the same way because
much earlier on in the process people
would have started you know threatening
us and and
stalking and all of the stuff that that
happens to women on the internet
disproportionately and anybody who
doesn't believe that that stuff happens
disproportionately to women on the
Internet just needs to make some female
friends who are on the internet because
I I mean I you know they're almost
everyone I know who's a content creator
who has more than about a thousand
average viewers has experienced that
kind of harassment and Hank and I have
had it but to a much much smaller extent
and much much later in our careers when
we were better able to deal with it you
know we had more resources we had more
support from people professional and
personal support so yeah I agree I don't
think we would have I don't think we
would have built I don't think we would
have built the same audience I think if
we'd done it we would have quit much
sooner
um and I yeah I totally agree
unfortunately I think that that's one of
the many many ways in which the Internet
is structurally misogynistic it is very
hard to know exactly but every female
youtuber I know has dealt with
harassment and stalking and like
legitimately threatening messages and
things that we really like even now kind
of like at that scale haven't
experienced and I have watched people
disengage from the platform amazing
content creators who do great stuff
either take long breaks which can really
you know hinder your growth on YouTube
or just go away and and stop doing it
and you know like get a no normal job
because of that and I and I I can't like
even like the people I know who have
pushed through and just done it and done
it and done it and like I when I hear
their stories or like I've even like you
know like talked to them about it and
they've sent me emails of what you know
like like forward me emails to be like
is this like something I should be
worried about like I got an email like
that I just be out I just can't even
imagine yeah no I me too I think that
yeah I think it's really it's horrifying
and it's a huge problem and it's an
undiscussed
prob
you hear all the time why aren't there
more women making YouTube videos and I
think the answer is pretty clear and
pretty straightforward which is that
it's not a safe space for a lot of women
and a lot of women don't don't feel safe
making YouTube videos and with good
reason I have great admiration for those
who continue to make videos in spite of
it I also have admiration for the people
who just say this is not going to be
part of my life because I have to stay
safe and do do work that where I feel
comfortable and not constantly
threatened yeah all right John well I
imagine that you have some news from AFC
Wimbledon but would you like me to do
the news from Mars first
yeah sure or whatever yeah sure whatever
so SpaceX you know SpaceX John Elon Musk
they not only I have had now two
successful
reusable rocket landings the second one
coming from a much higher altitude than
the first where these these Rockets have
come back to earth and landed themselves
on drone ships at sea it's just
remarkable to see and it kind of feels
impossible to me but there you have it
it's happening once to send a probe to
Mars a large probe to Mars larger than a
lander that would be larger than
curiosity which is I think the largest
thing we've ever sent to Mars so far by
2018 which is I mean I even musk is very
optimistic often with his timelines so
I'm not saying this is gonna happen in
2018 but that is really soon for a
mission that hasn't even like the lander
hasn't even been designed yet the the
rocket that would launch it hasn't ever
been launched to space so this is like
it's an ax modification of exist of an
existing rocket but it is a rocket
that's never been tested and like just
so ambitious but also very exciting and
and I think that the the it hasn't been
discussed too much but
my guess is that this would be a sample
return mission when we're talking about
the kind of mass that they want this
thing to be that's probably because it
would have to have on it enough fuel to
then launch back off the surface of Mars
and that means that they want to collect
some rocks and some dirt from the
surface of Mars and then and then launch
it back off the surface of Mars and have
it land on earth so that we can get
those rocks directly from the surface of
Mars and do research on them which is so
cool and been waiting for a Mars sample
return for my whole life and if we had
won by 2018 which would mean we would be
studying those rocks back from the
surface of Mars you know was in the
early 2020s that would just make my
dreams come true
well Hank speaking of dreams coming true
you may recall that just 14 short years
ago AFC Wimbledon was playing in the
ninth tier of English football two
combined Counties League and that today
they are a team in the fourth tier of
English soccer they are in the Football
League they are a full-time professional
team again the goal this season you'll
recall from the early podcasts was to
stay up to stay in the Football League I
never dared to dream that AFC Wimbledon
might find themselves in the playoffs
with a 25% chance of going up to League
One the third tier of English football
they're just too underfunded they're
owned by their fans not by some rich
person they don't have yeah I mean you
know they don't have some like fancy new
stadium although hopefully someday they
will and and yet and yet after winning
five straight games AFC Wimbledon found
themselves in a very good position to
get into the playoffs they then lost to
Portsmouth which was a disappointing
result then they were playing your
beloved Stevenage Hank you'll request
given each fan this couldn't have gone
better for me frankly because if if
Stevenage had won it wouldn't have
helped them out at all
no but if
but it would have been terrible for
Wimbledon correct but if Stevenage had
had lost then you know it would have
been like oh they lost that's kind of
sad but instead what happened instead
they tied 0-0 the money game or it
appeared that that was not enough but
then something amazing happened which is
that some team I can't even remember who
I think that there may be Ayala Plymouth
maybe Plymouth Rock I don't know all I
know is that some team scored against
Cambridge United in the last minute of
that game and because that game was a
tie AFC Wimbledon then qualified for the
playoffs which created this hilarious
and surreal situation in which AFC
Wimbledon players two minutes after
their game ended were suddenly
celebrating like crazy having tied
Stevenage AFC Wimbledon qualify for the
playoffs in seven spot the last of the
the last of the four playoff spots they
will play Accrington Stanley another fan
own team Hank by the way at in the semi
finals it's home in a way so first
Accrington Stanley will come visit AFC
Wimbledon and on May 14th which will be
after this or before this podcast airs
so you people who are listening to this
now know of a future that is either very
good or very bad or possibly neutral and
then they will play at Accrington
Stanley in the second part of that home
away two-game series and then the
combined score of those two games will
decide who goes to the playoff final to
be played May 30th at Wembley Stadium
Hank this is like a 80,000 person
Stadium it would be just just it's just
unbelievable the whole situation is just
it's beautiful it's unbelievable it's
overwhelming it's terrifying it's it's
everything that human life can be and
the last thing I wanted to say on the
news from AFC Wimbledon is that
Wimbledon just played so their last game
against Newport County of the season was
essentially you know there wasn't
anything to play for they were all
gonna be seventh it didn't matter
whether they won or tied or lost but
they won that game they want it won de
nil because they got a penalty and
audible Aachen phenoix the 34 year old
largest and greatest both in terms of
mass and quality professional soccer
player in the world today was handed the
ball to take the penalty and it might be
Aachen fed was last game playing for
Wimbledon it might even be the last game
in his career for all we know he may be
retiring it's very possibly his last
game playing for Wimbledon though and
you know obviously you want to score in
your last game and he's a legend too AFC
Wimbledon fans but he chose not to take
the penalty instead he handed the ball
to an eighteen-year-old kid who was
making his debut that day and let him
take the penalty he scored AFC Wimbledon
1 1 nil and I think auto-buy lock and
phenoix showed that young man and
everybody who supports AFC Wimbledon
what what it is to be a good leader and
to be a good mentor and to be a good
teammate and I'm so so proud of this
team and I'm so excited I just hope that
they beat Accrington Stanley on May 14th
the player of the second leg is on May
18th so Hank that means on May 19th
which will be probably before we next
record a podcast isn't it won't it oh
gosh it may be and unless we figure out
a way to do it on the road
so before we next record a podcast I
will know whether I am going to be
spending May 30th in London or not wow
that's super exciting I am be crazy I am
very pleased and if you guys win this I
know it's too scary and I just the idea
of kicking that penalty kick to after I
can fend who gives me the ball I don't
know how I would even have hit the ball
I would have just just a bunch of grass
yeah I mean I do so these these playoffs
you know they can go they can go to
extra
time and then penalties in fact it was
you know because of playoff it was in a
playoff final that AFC Wimbledon made it
back into the Football League in 2011 on
on a penalty shootout I cannot imagine
taking a penalty shootout and you walk
up there and you put the ball on the
spot and you know that if you miss your
team will not like be promoted it's just
I can't I would I you're absolutely
right
I would not hit the ball I would I would
kick the air and then the referee would
have to make a decision as to whether
that counted as an attempt all right
well John what have we learned today
Hank before we wrap things up here I
have a quick update from the future this
is John from the future here AFC
Wimbledon has played the first leg of
their playoff semi final against
Accrington Stanley
it was the home leg it was nil nil in
the 90th minute it appeared that the
game would end that way but then Auto
bio aachen phenoix got a ball right on
the touch line passed it into the middle
there was a bit of a scrum and who
should emerge from that scrum to score a
goal but Tom bier you've never heard me
say that name Hank because Tom beer had
never scored a goal for AFC Wimbledon in
fact he'd never scored a goal in the
Football League he's an AFC Wimbledon
youth academy graduate who was recently
on loan to a sixth tier team who scored
in the playoff semi finals for his
hometown team AFC Wimbledon it was a
miracle it was beautiful everything was
beautiful
nothing hurt now on Wednesday
they will play Accrington Stanley in the
second leg of that semi final if they
win or tie they they go to Wembley and
that would mean that I would also go to
Wembley so that is the update on AFC
Wimbledon incredibly exciting stuff Hank
all I'm saying is that I think that
we've learned that AFC Wimbledon win or
lose is probably the greatest collection
of human beings in the history of this
planet possibly even Mars probably if
anyway we learned too too
that skinny fries are just better
because of the starch to oil Chris penis
ratio we learned that toxic megacolon is
not just something to be feared but also
something to be listened to and we
learned to never ever ever ever under
any circumstances but especially when
containing an earbud should you touch
John Green's ear really just don't touch
the ears of strangers I think that's
pretty like fundamental human fact never
never do that thanks for listening to
our podcast which is edited by nicholas
jenkins our intern is claudia morales
rosianna halse rojas helps us out with
the questions our theme music is by
gunnarolla you can email us at Hank and
John at gmail.com if you'd like to ant
ask us a question or you can go to the
Twitter and use the hashtag dear Hank
and John I'm hey I'm Hank green on
Twitter no I'm not I'm John Green on
Twitter Hank is Hank green you can also
follow us on our preferred social
networks snapchat where Hank is Hank GRE
and I and I am John Green's naps John
Green's naps and we have if you would
like to help us produce the podcast to
help pay our intern and and Nick our
editor you can help us out at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John and
as they say in our hometown don't forget
the awesome
you
[Music]